my name is Ignacio stone my married to
Edward Hale stone we call him chip I'm
Edward Hale stone must've systems hunter
I'm a subsistence gatherer
fisherman I'm married Agnes and I have
five daughters I tried to get them all
involved in everything from caribou to
seals in the ocean to fish in the river
to birds flying overhead to digging
stuff out of the ground we got to be
kind of nomadic and change our camps and
go where the animals are or we have to
go where the fish are or we have to go
where the plants are blooming or the
berries and sometimes we have to go
where the weather tells us to soak we're
spending the spring here in the Kowalik
cuz this to us is the place to be
hello wine warm temperatures and long
days allow the hailstones to live off
the land in Kowalik they'll spend the
summer harvesting the area's vast
resources in order to survive the harsh
winter ahead we've got some important
things to do we're gonna have to set up
the tents we're gonna have to set up our
kitchen gonna have to go get some
willows and grasses to make our beds
just generally set things up the way we
like them in the summer time and be here
till August ok we gotta start moving for
the weather coming towards evening it's
gonna get cold and start getting moist 1
2 3 let's go all together up to you
I need Michael you need you can yep hold
on to a rope babe it's all you got to do
yeah
it's bulky is what it is okay okay stop
you guys oh those are caribou
look at that we missed them it's a
pretty tough sell I think we probably
should just stick with the job we're
doing and hope they come a little closer
let's keep going 1 2 3 go if I wanted to
go after caribou that would be a
considerable effort and a considerable
amount of time to go up there to run
something down carry it back here would
be exhausting and then to have to put up
the tepee in the tent that would be even
worse so the whole idea is that once we
got the teepee in the tent up then I can
run off I can go get firewood I can go
chase caribou I can go do all that stuff
keep going forward love be careful it's
deep over here on this side
alright warned you getting our tents up
is the number one thing we have our
tents up then we're able to operate stay
dry without a good place to stay no fun
there we go right there okay whoo well
it's gonna rain you guys let's get this
up and let's make a place to cover our
stuffs no we gotta we gotta fix um it's
important to have shelter as fast as you
can we've got rain coming and we have
tons of work to do but what we do is we
cover our bases first so that if
anything happens to leave that home
pretty good job girls looks like you'll
be sick here it's gonna hold for thrush
this summer so we're gonna just knock
off for the night and we'll start out in
the morning and see what we come up with
you